[Aplausos]
[Música]
verano de 2022 todo el donbass está
ocupado por los rusos comento todo no
todo no diversas zonas defendidas por
irreductibles galos digo ucranianos
resisten todavía y como siempre al
invasor por desgracia para ucrania la
clave de su resistencia no es ninguna
poción mágica sino el apoyo de occidente
y aunque las cosas se desarrollan de una
manera muy diferente a la planificada
por el kremlin rusia logró hacerse con
un 20 por ciento del territorio de
ucrania en los primeros 100 días
transcurridos desde que diera comienzo
la guerra si fracasaron en tomar kif y
cada metro de avance le está saliendo
muy claro al ejército ruso pero también
a ucrania que está perdiendo una gran
cantidad de hombres y está viendo
destruidas muchas infraestructuras
críticas por los ataques rusos pero en
esta ocasión nos alejaremos un poco del
frente o al menos de lo que todos
identificamos como tal porque lo que
queremos con este vídeo es echar un
vistazo al papel que está jugando en la
guerra lo anunciado por el presidente de
ucrania el 24 de febrero el mismo día
que dio comienzo la invasión el esquí
dijo esto
lloro whiting y dos de maig andan los
mensajes estaba entre todas las
proyecciones de títulos live 3 realmente
borbón y equilibró mayormente
es por un wing 12 donde serás correcta
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas estas unidades de
defensa territorial son un componente de
la reserva militar de las fuerzas
armadas de ucrania están movilizadas
desde finales de febrero y en los
últimos años han mejorado notablemente
sus capacidades así que la pregunta es
en qué momento surgen las fuerzas de
defensa territorial cómo se organizan y
cuál es su modus operandi y lo que es
aún más importante qué papel están
desempeñando en el actual conflicto con
rusia hoy en visual político vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historias
[Música]
rosa y la espada
la desintegración de la unión soviética
generó una gran incertidumbre además de
rusia otras tres antiguas repúblicas
soviéticas se habían quedado en su
territorio con armas nucleares era el
caso de bielorrusia de kazajistán y por
supuesto de ucrania donde queda a
disposición del nuevo gobierno de que ni
más ni menos que el tercer arsenal
nuclear más grande del mundo por aquel
entonces nos encontrábamos al final de
la guerra fría como os podréis imaginar
después de pasar décadas al borde del
cataclismo nuclear eso de que otros tres
países se unieran al club del armamento
atómico aparecía la mejor idea así que
tal y como decimos por aquí en visual
político dicho y hecho en 1994 eeuu
reino unido y rusia filmaron con estas
antiguas repúblicas soviéticas
el memorándum de budapest este acuerdo
supuso que estos países entregaran su
arsenal nuclear a rusia a cambio de
recibir garantías de seguridad por parte
de eeuu gran bretaña e ironías de la
vida la propia rusia y claro aquello no
fue el mejor estímulo para que ucrania
invirtiera en defensa y modernizar a su
ejército
[Música]
como tantas y tantas otras cosas de la
era soviética el servicio militar
obligatorio y es una reliquia de la que
la ucr han independiente lleva décadas
tratando de deshacerse los tres años de
servicio militar en tiempos de la unión
soviética se han reducido a un período
de entre 12 y 18 meses y aunque la mili
favorita en 2013 tuvo que ser
restablecida el año siguiente después de
que rusia comenzara a apoderarse del
territorio ucraniano
[Música]
para entonces el pueblo de ucrania se
había levantado y ya dos veces contra el
títere de putin el presidente viktor
yanúkovich una en la 'revolución
naranja' por amañar las elecciones y
otra en el euro maidán por romper un
acuerdo de asociación con la unión
europea fue el momento en el que
aprendieron por primera vez que llevar
la contraria putin no sale gratis los
ucranianos se llevaron un buen golpe de
realidad la anexión de ucrania y el
comienzo de las hostilidades en el
donbass por parte de las guerrillas pro
rusas dejaron en evidencia a sus
autoridades que ucrania sólo tuviera
seis mil soldados preparados para el
combate fue el resultado de décadas de
corrupción un desastre que han tratado
de solventar en los últimos años
como podéis ver ucrania ha invertido
mucho en modernizar su ejército desde la
invasión de crimea parece que les ha
quedado claro que el memorándum de
budapest tiene ya menos valor que el
pacto de varsovia pero en 2014 el
problema de ucrania era del todo
evidente el ejército regular era
insuficiente y contaba con un
presupuesto que apenas rondaba el 2% del
pib de uno de los países más pobres de
toda europa lo que supone que en 2014 el
gasto militar apenas superaba los 2.500
millones de dólares una cantidad
claramente insuficiente para el que es
el país más grande de todo el viejo
continente ante semejante panorama
ucrania confió su suerte a
organizaciones de voluntarios que
estaban dispuestos a defender a su
patria
[Música]
la guerra del donbass causó un gran
quebradero de cabeza en kiev ante la
táctica rusa de apoyar a las guerrillas
de dones y lugares así como a diferentes
grupos insurgentes ucrania puesto por
una fuerza a medio camino entre lo civil
y lo militar querían que fuera capaz de
organizar una guerrilla en la
retaguardia rusa que incomodar a los
invasores y que en el terreno propio
fuera útil como complemento del ejército
ese fue el momento de los conocidos como
batallones de defensa territorial
[Música]
como bien sabéis el conflicto del
donbass se extendió hasta nuestros días
así que una preocupación que enseguida
surgió en el gobierno de ucrania fue
cómo absorber a estos batallones de
defensa territorial dentro de la propia
estructura del estado durante años se
produjo un debate político eterno sobre
cuáles serían sus competencias y
cometidos pero la idea siempre ha sido
que sean un complemento al ejército sin
pretender nunca reemplazar su papel el
caso es que tanto se largo el asunto que
no fue hasta el pasado 1 de enero cuando
entró en vigor la ley de fundamentos de
la resistencia nacional es entonces
cuando todos estos batallones quedaron
incorporados en un nuevo cuerpo las
fuerzas de defensa territorial un nuevo
cuerpo que nació apenas 50 días antes
del comienzo de la invasión rusa
las fuerzas de defensa territorial están
constituidas por 25 brigadas cada una al
servicio del mando militar de cada obras
esto es de cada región de ucrania en
todo caso todas ellas son en última
instancia coordinadas por el cuartel
general ubicado en kiev y la ley
estipula que cada brigada debía listar
unos 3.500 hombres divididos en
batallones de 600 esto supone que las
fuerzas de defensa territorial contarían
con unos 90 mil efectivos
apenas 20 días después de que la ley
entrará en vigor el entonces máximo
responsable de las fuerzas aseguraba que
ya estaban preparados de esta forma
mientras rusia no paraba de acumular
fuerzas en la frontera con ucrania el
mensaje que enviaba kif es que estaban
preparados que las cosas habían cambiado
y que en esta ocasión no les iban a
pillar por sorpresa que fue exactamente
lo que ocurrió en el año 2014 y un hija
luskin comandante de las fuerzas de
defensa territorial la demanda de armas
de fuego y municiones de la fuerza de
defensa territorial está totalmente
cubierta al constituirse a brigadas en
los territorios que ya estaban en
conflicto como dones y luján está claro
que quien ya estaba pensando en que
estas fuerzas deberían actuar como una
especie de guerrilla o movimiento de
resistencia si finalmente los rusos se
adentraban en ucrania algo así como una
fuerza partisana para mantener viva la
llama
un cuerpo para controlar la seguridad
del territorio brindarle apoyo logístico
a las tropas inteligencia realizar
emboscadas y operaciones de sabotaje o
construir y reparar infraestructuras
militares la idea es que la defensa sea
mucho más densa y por tanto que el
invasor tenga mucho más difícil
controlar el territorio el caso es que
como todos sabéis la invasión finalmente
se produjo así que la pregunta es qué ha
hecho esta fuerza de defensa territorial
desde entonces qué papel está jugando en
la guerra de ucrania pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
zanja
el 24 de febrero comenzó la invasión a
ucrania el avance ruso inicial fue
demoledor avanzando desde bielorrusia e
intentaron en volver kif del este
llegaron hasta las inmediaciones de
jarquín y reafirmaron su dominio sobre
dones y luhansk en el sur avanzaron
desde crimea y tomaran melitópol y
gerson antes de comenzar el brutal
asedio de mariupol llegados a este punto
los ucranianos de las zonas ocupadas
tuvieron que poner en práctica lo
aprendido durante los últimos años
nuestra gente está haciendo todo lo
posible para asegurarse de que la tierra
arda bajo los pies de los ocupantes iván
fedor of alcalde de melitópol desde que
diera comienzo la invasión muchas
ucranianos se han sumado a las fuerzas
de defensa territorial las cifras
oficiales indican que en marzo ya eran
unos 100.000 la verdad es que ucrania no
está teniendo problemas de efectivos
pero ahora bien hay que diferenciar en
estas fuerzas dos tipos de soldados muy
diferentes por un lado el voluntario
civil que con suerte antes de la
invasión dedicó algún fin de semana a su
adiestramiento pero que evidentemente
carece de conocimientos militares y
luego por el otro están los
profesionales de las fuerzas armadas y
otros cuerpos de seguridad que son los
que ocupan el rol de oficiales dentro de
este cuerpo de hecho muchos veteranos de
la guerra del donbass optaron por entrar
en estas fuerzas tan necesitadas de
unidades experimentadas para instruir y
guiar a los nuevos voluntarios el
problema hoy día es que muchos de estos
soldados han optado por ir al frente
porque están mucho mejor pagados y donde
pueden tener una contribución mayor en
la defensa nacional en cualquier caso
una de las principales ventajas de los
voluntarios civiles es su conocimiento
del terreno jugar en casa les
proporciona ventaja para identificar
cuáles son los lugares claves a defender
organizar emboscadas o detectar
rápidamente a los infiltrados rusos
[Música]
gracias a ellos se han producido la
mayor parte de los arrestos a grupos de
sabotaje que trabajan para el kremlin en
ucrania y por supuesto estos voluntarios
han sido armados desde el primer día
desde que el presidente del skeet
declaró la ley marcial armas para todos
se forman milicias a lo largo de ucrania
mientras las fuerzas rusas se acercan
amigos amigas el objetivo fundamental de
las fuerzas de defensa territorial es
llevar a cabo tareas básicas lejos del
frente pero que requieren un alto número
de efectivos hablamos por ejemplo de
levantar puestos de control en las
carreteras principales cavar zanjas y
trincheras hacer labores de vigilancia
seguimiento fortificar posiciones y
barricadas en fin actividades de las que
se pretenden liberar al personal del
ejército propiamente dicho para que
éstos puedan centrarse completamente en
las misiones de combate
[Música]
otra función asignada a las fuerzas de
defensa territorial es participar
activamente la búsqueda y detección del
enemigo en retirada por ejemplo son
capaces de realizar con bastante
eficiencia las llamadas operaciones de
limpieza lo que incluye el rastreo y la
captura de pilotos rusos de aviones y
helicópteros derribados el objetivo está
claro no dejar ni un enemigo atrás para
proteger la retaguardia del ejército
ucraniano
por supuesto en los territorios ocupados
su labor es más peligrosa se necesita
tanto valor para sus actividades como el
que los soldados de ucrania están
mostrando en el frente ahora si las
noticias que llegan desde estas zonas
son constantes desde ataques a una base
aérea controlada por rusia hasta la
destrucción de un tren blindado e
instalaciones ferroviarias en melitópol
todo nos sirve para luchar contra el
invasor ruso y cuando decimos todo esto
dos civiles ucranianos matan a soldados
rusos con pasteles envenenados en españa
se suele decir que lo que no mata
engorda en ucraniano
[Música]
lo que está claro es que la vida ha
cambiado mucho en el país para los que
antes del 24 de febrero eran maestros
ingenieros obreros y también para las
empresas de la noche a la mañana se han
reconvertido en parte de una economía de
guerra que está trabajando día tras día
con un único objetivo expulsar a los
rusos y al igual que el pueblo de
ucrania se ha puesto al servicio de la
patria con sus fuerzas de puesta
territorial hay empresas que están
haciendo exactamente lo mismo
el mes pasado hacían alta costura ahora
están haciendo botas de combate el éxito
de ucrania en la defensa de kif hizo que
los rusos pasaran a centrarse en su
ofensiva en el este y sur del país a
alejar al enemigo de la capital ha hecho
posible que miles de efectivos de las
fuerzas de defensa territorial tienen
ahora a disposición de los mandos
militares para actuar más cerca al
frente claro que hay dudas acerca de si
esto es o no lo más conveniente atentos
[Música]
y combate de los jefes
el esquí siempre ha sido partidario de
que ucrania tenga un ejército más
profesional tres hembras antes de que
diera comienzo la guerra el presidente
ucraniano firmó un decreto en el que
apostaba claramente por aumentar el
presupuesto de defensa y subir los
salarios de sus fuerzas armadas del
mismo modo se fijó para 2024 el final
del servicio militar obligatorio pero
claro la invasión rusa lo ha cambiado
todo y parece que también la opinión del
propio keller es que esto ha provocado
que a mediados de mayo se produjera una
noticia sorprendente que no ha tenido
ninguna explicación oficial el esquí
despide al jefe de las fuerzas de
defensa territorial de ucrania porque
fue despedido jury hallows quien cuando
tan sólo habían transcurrido 80 días de
guerra no estaba acaso haciendo un buen
trabajo
[Música]
a la vista de cómo se ha defendido
ucrania está claro que si no puede ser
el motivo a ver sin duda el mérito de
repeler a los rusos debe atribuirse al
valor de los soldados de ucrania pero
también se ha hecho un buen trabajo en
la segunda línea entonces a qué vino
esta destitución en su momento hubo
rumores de que hallú skin podría tener
ciertas aspiraciones de entrar en
política explica acaso esto que zelinski
quisiera fulminar le antes de que ganara
popularidad y pudiera convertirse en un
rival político la verdad es que cuesta
pensar que el presidente ucraniano tenga
tiempo para este tipo de cálculos vamos
con echar a los rusos bastante tiene ya
por eso la clave de esta destitución
quizás tenga más que ver con una noticia
que se produjo apenas dos semanas antes
del cese deja los kings mirad lo que
aprobó el parlamento de ucrania a
comienzos de mayo en la rada permite que
la defensa territorial lleve a cabo
tareas en áreas de guerra de esta forma
la rada modificó la ley de fundamentos
de la resistencia nacional cuatro meses
después de entrar en vigor
[Música]
el principal cambio es que las fuerzas
de defensa territorial operan en todo el
territorio de ucrania incluidas las
áreas de operaciones militares y de
combate otro detalle también es muy
significativo la decisión de ir a estas
zonas no la tomará el comandante de las
fuerzas de defensa territorial sino el
comandante en jefe de las fuerzas
armadas de ucrania y mucho ojo al modo
en que se ha aprobado esta reforma
legislativa
según el artículo 94 de la constitución
de ucrania el jefe del estado debe
firmar una ley que se le envíe en un
plazo de 15 días o devolverla al
parlamento con propuestas razonables y
motivadas si el presidente no firma la
ley en dicho periodo y no la envía al
parlamento entonces la ley entra en
vigor y esto es exactamente lo que
sucedió con esta reforma ya que es de la
scj y no la firmó ni la devolvió en el
plazo pertinente tras ser aprobada por
la rada
porque no siguió el esquí el
procedimiento habitual previsto por la
constitución posiblemente estamos ante
una señal de que se ha impuesto el deseo
de los mandos militares de ganar más
efectivos para combatir a los rusos en
el frente quizás el presidente no
quisiera firmar la ley haciendo que la
responsabilidad de equiparar a los
voluntarios civiles con los soldados
profesionales recaiga sobre los
parlamentarios de la rada que aprobaron
esta ley
[Aplausos]
ahora bien todo indica que el comandante
de las fuerzas defensa territorial se
opuso con firmeza a la decisión de
enviar a luchar a sus miembros tanto que
aceleró es que no le quedó otra que
destituirlo la cuestión es que a los
kings no es el único que piensa que las
fuerzas de defensa territorial no están
preparadas para luchar en primera línea
mch william bishop como pasado militar y
periodista freelance que colabora con
prestigiosos medios internacionales está
sobre el terreno y opina exactamente lo
mismo
ucrania ha enviado a toda prisa a todas
las unidades disponibles a la lucha en
el este incluidas varias brigadas y
unidades de voluntarios mal entrenadas
de las fuerzas de defensa territorial
pase un tiempo con una de las unidades
de voluntarios que fueron trasladadas al
frente y fue una experiencia alarmante
sin ser su culpa estaban siendo enviados
a la batalla con un equipo mínimo y sin
un entrenamiento básico adecuado el
análisis de bishop asegura que estas
unidades siguen sin estar preparadas
para el campo de batalla no tienen ni
idea de las tácticas más básicas de la
infantería lo que les convierte en un
blanco fácil para los rusos
está claro que los ucranianos están
dispuestos a darlo todo por su patria
también la vida pero como comprenderéis
tampoco se trata de hacer sacrificios en
vano para poder cumplir su misión los
ucranianos necesitan dos cosas armas
modernas y entrenamiento para lo primero
cuentan con la ayuda de occidente el
entrenamiento y eso ya es algo más
complicado necesitan tiempo y en la
guerra el tiempo es un bien escaso sea
como sea si algo está claro es que esta
fuerza de defensa territorial está
jugando un papel muy relevante en
ucrania tanto que países como polonia ya
han empezado a copiar está estructura
pero dicho esto turno para ti estás de
acuerdo con utilizar todos los efectivos
disponibles para combatir al invasor
ruso deja nuestra respuesta en los
comentarios como siempre y te resulta
interesante este vídeo no olvides darle
al botón de like y compartirlo con tus
amigos díaz tampoco suscribirte a visual
político un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]